now we turn to wall street where stocks
had their worst day in nearly two years
yesterday there was a huge sell-off
after major retailers announced a drop
in their profits cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger is here to help
us out like she always does jill good
morning it seemed like stocks were
starting to stabilize
why such a big sell-off we had two big
companies target and walmart reporting
their quarterly earnings and both
companies said something very similar
they are paying more for a lot of their
costs they're not passing that all on to
consumers and at the same time their
favorite customers are coming into the
stores but they're not buying as much
and when you think about target and
walmart they're kind of bellwethers for
us for consumers and so now the fear is
among investors uh-oh high prices people
not spending as much corporate profits
going down maybe there's a recession and
oh boy did we see that selling escalate
yesterday we'll talk about investors in
a second but speaking of recession is
this a sign that a recession is coming
sometimes we look at the stock market
it's called a forward-looking indicator
but you know stocks can sell off and
actually not mean that there's a
recession coming i think we're on the
cusp right now remember recessions are a
normal part of the business cycle so we
will have a recession it's a scary word
for people here is and you know what
it's scary because when that when you
have a recession you can have job losses
and wages might stop going up and there
could be a period here where things slow
down and wages are not rising enough to
actually afford all the stuff that's
getting more and more expensive and i
see you're wearing red which is the
color of love danger anger and adventure
so for investors which one of those
feelings should they latch on to you
know that little voice in your head that
says don't just sit there do something
yeah i want you to reverse it i want you
to say
don't do something just sit there don't
panic stick to your game plan if you
need money within 12 months you've got
to get out but if you don't need any
money within 12 months stay the course
you're investing for decades in the
future i know it's hard to do
deep cleansing breath just relax don't
panic cry you're the best dollar dollar
joe thank you so much